it's been a gas you know it's just been
so much fun I think it's it's great for
me but you know the right is all about
me now and so long what's right for me
and I think because Clara adopter feel
more in a groove I think that they are
really enjoying being the luckiest
people in all of history because they
get to play with his advanced toy box
which is tight space the universe and
they throw themselves recklessly you
know into the pursuit of adventure which
is lovely that's a whole kind of
different tone that's a whole kind of
you know it's tangible it's fun
it's a way to be in it's clever we also
have made rubber suits protective
monsters which is one of the great
things about Doctor Who you will always
have there's a b-movie and it still
survives along with though the
philosophical but I think one of the
great you know most people say what was
it like when did you first feel like
talk to you I think it was where they
through and I rather spider at my face
and said fight it
where's the altimeter this is there is
no operator it's just a big rubber
spider so yeah you know it's been good
it's been this kind of a freedom I think
to us both being in our it's off glory
these and it's kind of really adrenaline
fueled and all about living in the
moment and pushing the adventure right
up to the edge and obviously with that
comes my extraordinary danger policeman
it's just fitting very fun to be choose
running at all from I mean you know
there was a suffered a pretty great
tragedy a change of perspective and a
change of you know the ideas life it's
short and I want to live it and feel it
and feel alive and hang out with my best
mate in the TARDIS and I think that's
all all she wants yeah I mean it's just
the idea that you could do that and
still be a teacher I've been a teacher
at the same time I mean can you you
think it depending could never have a
normal life again and what once their
lives been touched in that way but I
think that's part of the problem is is
that once you once you've painted it
open and then open that covered and seen
all the time in space how do you go back
how do you go back to living on earth
and living a normal life I think that's
I think it becomes addictive and
anything that's causing a problem
yeah for you Michelle at the end of last
week we saw you vanish you seemed sad
not that the plan didn't work so much
it's just like oh I guess I don't get to
have my friend
after all so what type of renewed energy
do you feel like is taking you into
series nine like where's where is just
going to be coming from now and she must
have come which is kind of surprising
and exciting to play as well slightly
different dynamic to her and to be
honest doesn't quite believe that maybe
Oxley by and so himself
relishing that gem so she's yeah there's
something that's slightly different to
her and I don't know whether it's
because of the tiny was taken and to
finish a lot of series and then come to
this one what what she's been doing in
between which can imagine probably take
the TV Queen does quite like T so just
wait feet so very cold I mean am I crazy
first feels like with this doctor he
just lets anyone on the like there was
so many different people or just like
sure come on I'm a time traveler tiny
space baby ceases they were trying to
seem like there was a bunch of art with
the open-door policy with the TARDIS in
series
well because go such a friendly face
I think the doctors got more relaxed
there meaning the old series at the
beginning even restricted under the
TARDIS and yeah it's true but along
bio-memories is basically saying yes
it's bigger on the inside get over it
maybe if you think about it and that's
like this one as a kid watching the show
and about not be what we want I used to
wonder what the doctor didn't more often
use that as a you know you know I really
am an alien from Mars you don't believe
me okay look at that that's that's an
alien from outer space is there okay
it's bigger on the inside
why didn't you ever do that is why I
always just wonder when I was a kid I
see it was only me my mom was right
actually I got a good offer and instead
applause from my imaginary girlfriend
virginity kept me pure do you feel like
do you think he's becoming gentler do
you feel like it's passion or do you
feel like I mean do you think you think
this is pretty nice so these are nice
color cuz he comes up kind of abrasive
sometimes to people and he's too fat
with us he's a wonderful guy he said I
really want to he's a laugh
he's uh he's great looking it's
terrifically live for his age
yeah I think he's you know I you know
which does live in a world where
everybody was supposed to be so anybody
so easy if you so accessible the doctors
experience
he should know it's not a guy you know
he's a special child I didn't know well
they he even has a comparable being made
protecting us to everyone but he made
this not totally different planning
she's got a guy but if it was a guy he'd
have my face
about the share with the social
situations
Clara teaches him how to interact with
humans
a little bit more this season because we
know the right things to say in the
right situations what do you think he
thinks reason with the human one-on-one
like what is but it's great to see news
actually Clark does complement social
skills tries to make more over a welcome
party guest the doctor I play why with
begun about to come TARDIS question I
always building as a kind of guy and say
you know you walk through these doors
come with me come with me
yeah I'm sure
what is what is your name question yeah
well with the new doctor mr. I'm sorry I
was talking about McCory
with the news he sings a minute long and
how they interacted in the last season
how about the dynamics B now since we
know she's trying his best friend and
this friendship so how about dynamic
change for season 9 I think that
disappeared the question well I mean the
way shaky when Missy comes back into the
doctors life ensign is not something
you're probably going to predict it's
very very different
I don't think this is a new idea by the
way the doctor and the master be good
friends I have one of the first things I
did when I started writing that just go
back and look at the Jon Pertwee Roger
dog and aubergine are they labs the
south of elderly fans clapping it's a
little bit
as best friends you know one of the ones
that blow off the world one of the ones
this stop it blowing on but hey you
can't let those little things get in the
way
can you and you might be self go to a
gentlemen's club and about share some
around they have to and so it's that's
not you that's so we do play men but you
don't worry she's just as violent
psychopathic as ever in an ugly way
I thought Thank You Piper Laura and I
assume you are as well convincing human
you've built with you oh my god hi I
just whose eyes have one Steve Jenna and
Steven remember me from my make-a-wish
in 2013 oh yeah hello again and I
believe help you get your why and what I
want to ask is this is a would everyone
that every filming hero companion even
white dude has something iconic about
that he about the killer do about about
the way got the tone to this and they
put to the story what do you think is
yours that's a way better question than
anything I said your doctor I mean my
specific they are
you guys say this I probably as I Jenna
what about you oh my goodness no I
didn't eyes eyes when she plants which
would she absolutely plants on him and
then episode I was kind of wondering if
I were watch back is there even a second
where he was like I know what this is
or it's still because it freaks him out
whenever someone shows them affection
yeah the question is have you kissed who
just didn't let go and I think if you do
play a five in a few you are imagine a
Boston and you see that it's a pizza is
really there's some suction there
it was one take wet Michelle the hell of
my hand yeah throughout the kids what
you didn't see was that I was actually
also holding far as hot as I think the
answers are learn about the dynamic with
season nine
did somebody just say that oh no that's
hot she's I think is all too tall no she
sent that time yes what is your name
what's your question Bridgette oh my
questions for Jenna
I was wondering how you transition from
working with Matt Smith to Peter Capaldi
how you felt about it well I was pretty
young me rollercoaster day I think it's
fair to say there aren't many shows
where you switch the lead up to benzene
literally through the handshake in a
sort of the costume watch because
there's only four of them and I was it
was it just happened and we came back
and began to shoot a whole new Doctor
Who in the in the January but yeah there
was a I was oh it was a rollercoaster it
was it was to be Lincoln single biter to
want a friend and very excited and then
go to another all at the same time
yeah this was the magic of the show that
I think as you know if you're a die-hard
fan of the show it's always
heartbreaking when you watch a
regeneration episode and you cry about
for a couple days and then you're a
little yeah
don't go anywhere
interesting
like lost but getting new people and
accepting new life you know the show is
just like what is your question my
question is for everyone what are your
opinions on eventually having a female
doctor you said everyone but I don't
think I can say well that is no thinking
safe is worth point that you just met
the actor Paula Deen's there when you
leave that is convicted well I think my
opinion is fairly obvious from this show
is maybe what I think about the
possibility and whether it would work or
not I think I think I've expressed
myself about as clearly as I could in
the context of the show if you're not
reading the subtext then but believe me
some people aren't reading that subject
because it's too
yeah and I'm not going to reveal reveal
myself as a man today would be such a
disappointment especially for Jack I'm
sure it will happen at some point I
think it's just about casting the right
actor and she's going to change costume
or anything
let's do a drag episode system yeah in
the past years we dr. who is found again
everyone will remember you as a writer
what is your greatest inspiration in
literature and what is your most fun oh
it's such a depressing answer making
myself for the sake of this panel I
threw in saying the blacks amazing
one day my parents were surprised I
haven't spoken to them
so I was so inspired by dr. remember
with interests in television was the
fact that the doctor changed and I
couldn't understand why I heard what why
would they do that they mentioned in
like that it's going to because one
actor wanted to leave and another one
wants to come here and that's
interesting I didn't know they could do
that the idea that somebody would be
Doctor Who and then choose not to be
doctor as an adult as well as a writer
if you ever want to know how to write
screenplay
forget all those how to write a
screenplay books and just weave with
your Goldman everything every screenplay
where they go was ever written is
amazing so that's with me Neil Simon is
a god of comedy if you wonder how Comedy
Works assignment but really above all I
think the horror of Fang rock is really
cool that's a Doctor Who story for those
of you we're new so so this is like your
boring I said that's the one so with
your expert experience in all of the
previous seasons do you think that the
twelfth doctor would ever want to
to say that but I think you'd like to
and you come to the wrong when is the
ballroom in about half an hour my
question is for all three actors but in
particular miss Gomez it's because he
said that could you give us a brief
description of what your characters
ideal a perfect day would be day yeah
like a perfect Sunday like what's a
perfect day starting with Michelle so
just like squashing fake bugs
probably in the shape of who let me see
the biggest bugger all
I think chicken from her patented would
be starting with some tea made a little
cross so and then slapping wonder women
in the face
I suppose it's um teaching a bit of Jane
Austen follow by walking into the
stationery cupboard finger onto the
TARDIS and then Jack off to like kill
some octopus shapes aliens save the
world have a cup of tea with a doctor
and every night nice
I think I'm gonna get up have a nice big
pot of coffee read the papers think this
is very relaxing I really like this
thing get really bored and who come into
the night sky which would be artists in
the morning by could be on another
planet where morning is night our guests
let me go to a planet where morning is
night yes I think he'd be just every day
he just starts off wanted to have a nice
quiet time and then thinks oh this is
dull it's all out there maybe you want
there and go to the planet Skaro and see
where they ever held what do you think
he's so enamoured of humans budgetary
reasons
and one few Clinton given the
opportunity that the doctor and Sherlock
how do you Peter think personalities how
would you react more cleverly be alone
conversation about the doctor has
compassion for everyone and Sherlock has
compassion for no one yeah very
different yeah I'm not sure how will
they get off but for the record just for
the record no believes is I have no
problem with the idea of them it is all
the rest of them of the problem I'd do
anything for a laugh at art
we're good so in the world right now
this was being entertaining something
you've always liked dreamed of doing or
like a happy accident it was a very
happy accident I was I was one of the to
my children who answer is that running
mile in my childhood so my my first
experience was literally just getting
steven moffat sides of playing three
different characters in an audition and
I just had so much fun I loved it and
had a couple of meetings of that it was
it was so surprising how many different
versions of one scene you can play with
and have sharp and waiting and just fun
and funny that
writing was and is so it was an
extremely happy and very lucky accident
how did you feel your life changed from
this assessment it started airing with
you on the show I think it changed I'm a
Chinese really from that from that first
audition but it's the storytelling that
you get to do in the adventures and the
sets that you walk onto and the mad old
stunts and IANS in the green screen you
know the whole experience is really like
nothing else and then you step out of it
for a second when come to places like
this and get greeted by help so very
people it's um it's just it's just
incredible storytelling at its best with
somebody described it to me as an
imagination explosion I am I like that
this wiki you work most of the year and
so you probably imagine it's very
difficult for you to see the effect that
the show is having on people until you
come to an event like this what's it
like over in England is it is it similar
people similar in the kind of similar
over there yeah what did you imagine
because first came over yeah we melted
their brains because people think of New
York where people waited in line gaze
outside they were like oh my god I think
when art like this and it's really like
they were excited but it also like they
were like the reactions must were
generous and outgoing and you know the
way British people enjoy themselves in
public is quickly
I mean that was absolutely hilarious
yeah
and then it was no even I showed my love
due to Matt by trapping him for a
thousand years in a village yes
you have a very wet strange way of
expressing love
I hate them to death I use press
affection because there's an answer
coming up in the show excellent thank
you Tyrion said it's good to see you
again
I was wondering if you had any tips for
aspiring actors Hosting is what I read a
lot read enough books and read as much
as you can as somebody who's endured a
lot of rejection I'm an inspiration to
the younger clients because I keep
getting squashed like a bug out there
and I keep coming back so and my my tip
would be just just never give up and
this world is abundant and there's
enough for everyone that if you do give
up somebody else is going to take your
spoil anyway so you really just believe
in yourself
keep going you you'll get your Fineman
is insane
I can say just really could be seriously
Anthony but I do have a suggestion for
you which is the technology is basically
made it possible for you to just make
the thing that you want you know so just
make stuff make stuff don't be afraid to
make stuff don't be afraid to fail makes
up with your friends all right so what
it's like a writer and a producer form a
group put it on YouTube with your stuff
out in the world when you start pursuing
answers will start to reveal themselves
to you so you there are no excuses
anymore just make the stuff that you
want to see exist the world and then if
the business catches up with you gray
and if not you're making the stuff you
want and that's that you happen so
that's my advice
Jericho is so sorry yeah I'm on the Oh
love you guys
thank you coming here they're amazing so
you just wake that lady up
as to you Peter whatever you become
doctor like nothing not whatever you
wear the doctor do you ever feel all the
other doctors inside of you burning I'd
like some recipe left the sensation
do I feel the other type of time yeah
sometimes you do something you think
that's that's that's very tall or David
or John and they don't consciously try
to to emulate anything I think they're
all wonderful but certainly they they
they echo throughout the the show so we
do in the scripts there are moments of
resonance where there are bits and
pieces of things that I know have have
begun with us with another doctor and
I'm always very happy to play those
moments
excellent Thank You mr. Granger I think
we have one more question which is you
what is your name sir
hi my name is and I just say yeah
they're all wonderful people and
everything I appreciate you guys coming
down here and Jenna I just want you to
know that I can be the impossible boy -
you're impossible
you're like one of my favorite
companions my question goes back to you
Peter Matt just being in this series
what is I guess like the most amazing
thing that's happened to you that you're
expected to come from the show thought I
was an expert
yeah you know it's it's it's just an
extraordinary experience the whole thing
I mean I didn't realize the show I tell
you that the show is successful overseas
event that it was catching all in
America but I didn't realize it was to
this scale
to come here and find this wolf and
affection for something that I that goes
all the way back to my childhood
and I find myself in the center of now
is absolutely extraordinary but I you
know the most amazing thing that happens
is that you I get the affection for the
whole 50 years pointed in my direction
and that's great thank you very much
because you can it obviously totally I
was just gonna say how much I love Peter
Capaldi and how yes by one of my
favorite human beings and one of the
best ways about the job sorry to bury so
terribly is going to work every day the
TARDIS in this guy
it's called the TARDIS it can travel
anywhere in time space